I was very interested in fact that i wanted equality. Equality and parenting and shit parenting and.
All that we had a commitment to get those notions. I found that with young children that wasn't necessarily the kites.
There was i said so sinking back to the notion of it. That the mother would look after the children. And that that.
Men would go out and be active in the world.
So it's very was a really interesting consummated start negotiating that was going on to say look i don't want to
anyway and i'm on the importance. And the joy. Of nurturing young children.
It wasn't in any wife and they need to move away from sally and john of. My rights to equality and.
To encourage others to me specifically. To participate in equal parenting. And i think that's a whole other dog.
The points of nutrients of young children. And you know.
I think the longer that they really truly nurtured and kept away from institutions like schools.
Anyway building the house. So i decided to build a house. So i did.
And i got tremendous support from my extended family. I had virtually no money. Will.
I got tremendous support from my extended family and great support from sally and. Yes.
I mean john salley very helpful i used to help me saw through the door and through the things i learned.
But to see me in a different lot to many of the children i think that their mother was a builder
and their mother was active in providing their own shelter and things like that and i love to be able to
and i found that i love. The activity of building. I found it very.
I found it very liberating if i can use that fairly. Abused wood. Because i really.
I could make all my own decisions myself. I could have this building exactly as i wanted it.
I could build in whatever i wanted. And i could do it. It really wasn't so difficult and.
Really was for me the beginning of a lot of debunking of my own myths. I think you know.
I mean i think education's been very minute i think.
Shelter has been very on my main i say in recent times of course because traditionally
and i'm talking about you know hundreds and thousands of years ago. Women who.
All of those things the healers in the witches. And the educators and the builders. And the goddess.
So it was great for me to do that because it was really in keeping with my feminist. Growing feminist.
I got a lot of support from my friends it helped me to be very organized. Like a lot of the people in the family.
Several of the people in the would come and help me on a saturday. And i would just organize everything.
Get everything and then i just use this guy and generously donated to put all the pieces.
Put the pieces of the jigsaw puzzle together and thought it up the next day and. It was just great i loved it.
Many of my women friends came and helped.
And then started coming in asking how do you do this to imagine how do you do it and.
Are the tell them what i knew which i learned from other builders watching how the buildings being built.
Running down every friday afternoon at five o'clock and consulting bill chart of the local.
How much spice do you need around. How many millimeters g.-a leave you know. In the gap for a door and.
Various things like that.
So i'd gotten my get my knowledge from books and from people and from builders in every way i could
and then i was really happy to pass that information on the guy
and i think i mentioned earlier i really believe that full information is liberation in a way or is the way to. Growth.
So i thought was no reason that i should hold this information secret to myself.
And become part of the mycenaeans top club. So i was really happy to pass that information on to women and in.
So many women started asking me that had you do this
or how do you do that i thought i would just run a women's building course.
That might sound a very presumptuous and bold but.
You know we decided to start a school prom
or school so that our kids could be educated in animal caring loving creative way so we've done that
and i thought well you know i started school what's you know. Running courses for kids why not start.
And i've been teaching catherine join me in the school kids.
Particularly interested in teaching the young girls' schools.
So i sort of front of up to the local type college and so on a building course for women. And they were rather.
In the chapter woods agreement was rather shocked and surprised and scratched his head. So i did.
And that was great that was and i ran building courses for women for many. Not full time.
But every time i felt there was a need within any community like the newman community or broader communities.
When so i gathered enough. Women together. Wasn't that i gather them the sort of the interest would start to.
Simmer not so we'll gather a group of twelve to twenty women around you and
when you think you got the numbers will approach the college and. We were very lucky.
It was in those days of supporting women's education. And in fact.
Encouraging women's education particularly in nontraditional so-called. Non-traditional areas.
So i was very lucky to continue to be able to get funding to do that
and in the eighty's i've gone on to run a couple of courses which were not founded by a state government institution
or government institution but. Funded. Privately by women. And it's not that. So that's been fun. Yep that's spot on.
There was a lot of.
There was a lot of that show that is a must because we called the chauvinism in those days it's almost tended to stop
using i think. Yes. The notion of barefoot and pregnant. For women in long frocks as will. Was prevalent.
I mean it was one of the issues that are really felt uncomfortable about.
I didn't necessarily feel uncomfortable about it within my own household sphere.
Because we had some fairly strong women in that household. We all had our deficiencies and.
Hang ups and things like that but by sickly we encouraged each other in. You know. Focus to our interests.
But yeah that. That was very it still alarms me. It still horrifies me. That in the so-called. Alternative society.
That there is such an ism to use that would. There is such disrespect for women's equal rights.
I mean you know we still live in a society where women don't get equal priority.
You know women still get something like sixty seven percent of the average wage.
You know it's that's the broader community. And i don't think that the alternative society.
As you know diced and did very much for women's rights that while.
I know that a lot of women have gained their power and gone ahead and built houses and fixed cars
and been leaders of communities and community late is and.
We even have unfortunately now three women in this most city council who are older women
and women that are called older men still. I mean those things have occurred.
But i don't really even see this still very much. Shift of consciousness. Amongst most of the population. Around.
Women's rights. It's you know this is this this sort of. Is this sickness that strikes relationships.
Quite often when people hit her sexual couples who have children and it's sort of like.
I have this notion about radicals i'll talk about that my notion of radicals many of us were radicals was seen as
radicals were quite radical we were doing radically different things.
And one of my notions women of my theories about radicals is that. Come a certain i. Time.
And it's often ran about thirty and. People who are radical in the use sort of get confronted with this.
Energy why will something
and i go oh my god of i still got to keep making up the rules for myself about relationships about equality about work
about social issues all that sort of thing. And it is sort of you know the sort of a certain fatigue sometimes hits.
People about that i. And i think a lot of people who have been radical. Choose to continue to be radical.
And you know you see.
And i'm not sixty or seventy yet
but you know i hope on still fairly prepared to shine shit that i have this vision of may still be doing that ninety.
Helpfully. And i have everybody kicks me along particularly the kids to do that.
And so i think some people still radical. And i prepared to live a quiet.
Difficult life at thomas because you have to keep making up the rules there are no appropriate role models anywhere.
Nowhere in the world you know.
From in russia is crumbled and it was never it never got to you know treat women equally or anything like that.
So this is no way really that we see that as out there's not a role model school so we have to keep making it up.
I have to keep making up had a parent much a night children in a way that i hope will be lead to us having a long long
term loving relationship with each other and so we have to make it up.
And i'm prepared to do that but it takes a lot of energy it takes a lot of time.
And it takes a lot of research and reading and talking and actually my god you have to actually talk with people.
These ideas you know. You can't take anything. As given right.
And here sally and joan are giving a perfect example of sisterly brotherly love very advise thank you very much.
And there are others if you get hit by this energy why if you will figure out how to her by sickly i mean it's not a
conscious decision quite often. Of these people.
And who basically have come from very conservative backgrounds
and already does read of people's radical views have the reaction against conservatism.
And by sickly it's easier just to follow the model that mom dad grandma grandpa whoever it is to see it. And a lot of.
You know.
Right in the steamed radical leaders of the time of sunk back even to what i would consider considered to be fairly
conservative. Ways i mean i want to decide boring there but there's a real value judgment is in that you know.
And i try not to be too.
But it looks to me like these people are actually not particularly stimulated that's what i mean about boring.
By same bored by same fairly i'm stimulated and same to spend a lot of time
and energy trying to make life look very exciting doing.
Essentially great time consuming but fairly unstimulating things. That said that radicals. Aviva been very radical.
But maybe i don't know. I sometimes don't think i'm ready when other people say you.
I don't know the answer to that i don't really care. I just hope i keep growing and changing.
And i hope people boot me along the way to do it. You know. I'm still constructing new to constructing utopia.
Oh i don't think i'd be as arrogant as to say that i know that life can be pleasant.
I know that life can be fulfilling. Interesting.
I know it can be surreal life can be surrounded by people who are loving. Stimulating interesting.
I know the environment can be beautiful. I mean that's one of the other things that i've been.
Passionately involved with and that's the. Protection of the environment. And it was a whole other area of space.
So i think that. And i still. I'm not trying to create a utopia.
I think utopia exists in a way i mean the world is beautiful. Humans a beautiful of a species a beautiful.
Well we have to do is actually get away from our egocentric so it's. You know why and.
Be generous and be willing to move. And let that shine around us really. I know that sounds.
Not so that's why i'm here because the sightings like that's really cosmic. Far out man. You know it is i'm caught.
I'm quite spiritual in that extent that extent. I always have been i think.
And still since if you got to have a sense of humor i mean you know.
I take myself very seriously you know i take myself very seriously i take my humor very seriously.
There's a wonderful t.
Shirt a friend of ours on the farm used to raid which real used to stew so many people in that city and the humorless.
Him an ist. And i mean i just used to get such a chuckle a retard and that teisho. I know your story. And women.
I mean what always because of course we're going to talk about home birth number seven. Jonah. All of a geek.
Commonly known as bones.
Because i can talk about that now look at my lovely daughters selam i can also talk about her book which was beautiful.
Through. It's ok is it. As long as i have a little bit about your dressing and i will. I carry.
I decided to have my second child for we decided to have a second child at seven john's dad and and i
and we decided to have that child at home to have that the at home.
And so we went about gaining support for that now i might add here that. I lived at that time.
With people who were involved in the medical psychology. Social work professions. And so i went to pee. About it.
It was a bit of a freak at the idea of having a baby at home and. I was very clear.
Part of having a baby at home for me was about taking responsibility for myself and for my loss.
And that's what a lot of a lot has been about.
And that's why
when it's been so wonderful cause i've had that opportunity to take responsibility for all aspects of my life.
So i was prepared to take responsibility for the. Both of my second child. And by that i meant.
I was prepared to make decisions around. How it would be. Who would be. What i'd do the usual. Fee is that any any.
Pregnant woman goes through. And father is. You know what if the child is deformed or not normal. You know.
But i sickly if it's if it's a deformed what will i do.
And i was very clear about that i had gone through that with cells because i had my.
The doctor who was my birth assistant and heard the made him promise that if. Much all.
My firstborn child was born with. Obvious gross. Physical disability. That would require.
Gross amounts of medical intervention. To continue to sustain the loss of that child.
That he would promise he wouldn't take that medical intervention.
Now you know he quoted hippocratic oath to mean all sorts of things but they all got him to do that. I mean you know.
That was a very big seeing and it was a turning point in his career he said for me.
For him to actually realize that it was not against the hippocratic oath to let women take responsibility for their
birthing process to that extent. Ok so i was prepared to take those responsibilities and make those decisions.
Around the birth of my second child.
And on that very clear to our extended family members that died didn't feel responsibilities. That. As for example.
The doctor in our household. Felt. Mark for his were all his due. So we went about having a baby at hand and.
You know creating the nest getting. Carol. Stand on. Carolyn with. Norman stand. Dorothy smith.
To be a support team actually midwife and support team. And we all went into the life. And john i was born.
Was a beautiful who was foreman. Had calls an account beautiful woman in scope. Very well is one of the astrologers.
And there were nine people to join us to sell of course was this i was twenty three months old nearly two at that town.
And she had her loving. Abba mother beth with her as her support person.
And we were excel option i was born at six thirty i had in the morning and. I went into live about twelve.
That and not be who. And when it was obvious that the baby was coming soon sally was woken up and.
There she was i want to say her brother brought into the world. She knew all about the. The physicality of intercourse.
Birth and all the rest everything again you know. Knowledge is power. Or something like.
She was totally aware of what was happening. She knew where jonah was going to come out and.
The not be blood that might be water all of those things so i don't think she was particularly fice
and insane to me that it. And you know i have this image of sally.
In her little red dress again with the darkness down the front and being held lovingly by my. My sister beth.
As john a kind into the world i'm in.
And there were these nine people who fell in love with this baby as he literally popped that pretty little hand that
grabbed carol's finger.
And came into the world and then the rest of the family the rest of the fam came within minutes of his birth
and talked around and. Lauriston. I mean what i want to say about that was that.
It was just so wonderful the experience with sally had been sure to be in march this because i'd been in hospital.
I had felt very isolated i was the only woman who was.
Demand feeding her child in this hospital environment and i discovered this one other woman.
Fortunately who'd had six children.
And who actually taught me how to demand save much child in our blood had to demand food much of that is.
You had to get in this is to bring the child to you when the child walk up and prod.
Because we weren't allowed to have babies next to us during the not. That was a trauma for me.
All i wanted was my baby next to me and i would be all right thank you very much.
So the experience was that from that was i learned that i really want to be with me
when i was born thanks after was born and so that's one of the reasons i chose to have it. John returned.
And it was wonderful because a coyote gone to bed the not before i'd gone into lifeboat had a baby at six thirty eight
in the morning. I got up afterwards and had a shower and run the family.
In sydney at about eight o'clock and got this lovely little baby boy.
And are gone back to rest him for the rest of the day but i wonder you know.
When several of the goats and the cows in the trucks in the case in the docks. In the vegie garden.
And i mean just same to me that was just a part of life instead of it being this great big no you. It was really.
Very eventful. But my life. Went on as well very easily.
I wasn't a strange hold with taken away from my daughter she was there she sort of sat there and held him
and touched him and pushed and probably didn't try stiddy not remove. Cell putting a.
What is a tie slot possible tie stephen fonda and she sort of you know i mean.
That's not the sort of thing that can happen in a hospital and she tries very not assess it.
Because i'm in our new diabetes delicious all of this this. This beautiful. Succulent little.
New thing you know and so all of those things. We just felt like a continuation of my loss normally and. It was lovely.
It was wonderful. And from that. I decided well aren't enough of these women. So we formed the beyond group.
With food and i think just because you know that the time not have to look at the diets. Very much around.
And so carol. Another's. Phone booth and beyond. And we decided we'd help as many families as we could.
To have their babies. In the manner in which they said that if that meant. Supporting a woman to have a child.
In hospital we do that if it meant.
Supporting a want through as much of her leibert higher than it being necessary for her to go to hospital
or a big choice to go to hospital. Would do that if it meant. Choosing to have a diet have. We do that.
So i started to listen. I mean we free schools. And you know that involves taking risks.
And we're paid to do it and we had to negotiate with the medical profession in lismore cools to be.
Have them as our support people. When we didn't know what to do when we did encounter difficulties or difficult.
Things like that and. We had to face.
You know charges of irresponsible i don't think it's irresponsible to have you by be at home i think it's a very
responsible act. So i was a guy it was one of those very powerful targets for me.
And grew a lot through that experience. I loved helping women have their dieties of heart.
It was a it was a real it's an honest. Be around.
It's an honor to be around it and a lot of times i've moved towards helping friends towards their death. And it's been.
You know it's reclaiming the routes to a less pics of our lives.
It's reclaiming the right to have control over our lives. To provide shelter.
To provide education to provide food to provide birthing and death in a way that we that we want to do it.
How long was i mean than she i don't even lot putting use of it that.
You know i was in the to some of the most formative years of my loss. And. And i'm grateful for the experience.
I think they need.
I think it was something like a live news i did didn't because you see i live communally in the city
and it was all it's all part of the continuum is not where i'm on now.
You know i may not live at the beach but i still see myself as part of an extended family. So i lived in him than.
At the same sign community.
When my partner charlie and i met and fell in love and we lived part time a tangible fals and part time
and been trying to work out how we would negotiate.
The physicality of that you know where would we have had on assault.
But ninety i lived i stood at paradise but i'd never moved on from there to lift. And then. It was great.
Ok so it was a live news. Short. That was you know half a lot tamanna something i don't know.
And i don't really know how to put that into and sort of in woods because i'm just grateful for that experience and.
You know why i've never left him than. I are living. You know in a beautiful environment on the beach now and.
But you know it's like. It's still part of it still. When i think of her and that's part of.
My concept of time i mean i have very many when i think of hand. Many parts of the world in a y. Fit into that that.
Image for me now
and women certainly lads proud that i've still got lots of the friends they still have contact they have recently been
involved in teaching a course to thing i just say. It's not. I mean i don't even think that you have to leave places.
That's and that's part of what i think. I learnt.
Living at nimbin is that you can have these connections and bonds
and you don't even have to leave you just not there at the moment. So it's about how that attitude.
Why did and why did on the why from in the not being a better way of putting that question.
And that's that's a very long answer in a way.
It was after a long time of living in one place so i think i was really ready for a change.
I become in our bodies more and more. Involved in women's education and. I think a lot of the issues.
Of women's equality haven't been addressed. Or hadn't been addressed by. Most of the members of the community.
One of the difficult issues that we went through. Issues of. Incest within the family.
I didn't feel it as family adequately. Extended family adequately addressed those issues. To the satisfaction.
And to the to the recovery of the young children involved. Young women involved. And i really you know that was.
That was part of my i'd already moved to the coast. For work. Work was one of the reasons.
Some of the issues about care of the environment. Was certainly involved.
Some of the disagreements within the community about how we would actually kafer this very beautiful environment.
And it wasn't that i was opposed. I think i was just.
Because when i think in particular i think i was ready for china and i was ready to try to be in a situation where.
Not going to be in a situation where i could have.
Control of the some of the important choices i don't control in my negative why. More in the.
Getting it passed by being responsible for your choices. I'm not saying this very well. It's a bit muddled.
So i might have to rephrase some of this. Some of the reasons that i moved away from him than. Involved.
Moving to a place where we could. But charlie and i i pull to thought when we found work more easily.
With that long distance of travelling.
I was really ready for a change i think after a long period of commitment to communal living. At paradise valley.
I'm still love living communally in an extended family.
I wanted to be able to be in a situation where some of the social issues that are really important to me were really
being fully addressed within my own household. Some of those issues. And the issues of addiction.
I really want to live in a drug free. Household for myself and for the kids. I want to live in and.
You know a situation where people really a prepaid and bright enough to take on social issues like dealing with incest.
Which wasn't adequately dealt with in my view. In the community and issues of the environment. I don't.
I don't think we were able as a group. To come together very well and mike. Really significant. Radical.
Decisions about care of the environment.
And those with things that was what happening at the time that i was really ready to make my move and.
As those issues became difficult i mean you asked whether some loss there was very difficult because it was difficult
trying to not hold that up with you know many different people from different backgrounds and different audiologists.
We didn't have any bonding audiology you didn't have to pass a test to come there.
So is that i think that some of those issues were quite difficult and i was. I guess a little wearied of putting in.
Such intense energy. Constantly on some of those issues. And education. Was one of the issues that.
That was involved in mom. The kid's dad wasn't particularly satisfied with the notion of them.
Continuing ha school sort of education at navan and such
and i decided to be in a situation with the availability of hostels would be more acceptable to their dad and.
You know to make life easier and easier for the kids home.
So there were all these various issues that came into it and.
One of the issues was that we were ready to travel with the kids.
We promised the kids would take to what charlie promised the kids he'd take them to america and disneyland.
Before celebrates twelve and sadly very sort of was a reminder charlie.
Some twelve months old or two years before don't forget i'm nearly twelve and you have this promise.
So we actually had to make sure that we could earn our income. Own and have income to to take this wild adventure.
You know. Just heading off. Of the cities. So all of those. Influenced me.
And you know i just i just saw my moving on from in the debate is being just another opportunity for me to grow in
other ways. And to take a lot of the learning that i have learnt from him than into the broader community.
I mean you know like we were looking after our environment through the forest campaign that i was very intimately
involved with and things like that we were doing some of that we got the.
We got the rainforest policy for new south wales established we got the multiple occupancy trying to in local
government occur and things like that we disturb the schools. But here we were you know.
Cross bar
and by he's an environment still being ravaged so you know part of what i've done since being out here is to establish
with others and environments into he and. You know things like that so you know.
It's just an opportunity to to to go and expand somewhere else. Oh what a question.
The question being what made the community ineffectual with dealing with child abuse. Had three arkell.
Petry arkell of the life. You want me to repeat about what night it made it what.
Why was the community ineffectual in dealing with child abuse within the community.
I wish i really knew the answer to that. I cannot any.
I'm still only guessing at some of that and it's very easy to make generalizations.
I think one of the reasons the community wasn't effective in dealing with child abuse.
Was that many of the men in the community. Most of the men in the community by sickly.
Felt it was ok and really saddened to have to cite it.
I don't think that very many men were prepared to look at their own sexuality their own objectification of women
and children. And to come to group did make some growth steps through that.
I think many of the men felt all year but all been a bit like that miss so. Therefore it must be ok.
I don't think there were very many women who were brave enough to speak out against their partners although in product
conversations with me many of the women would. When it came to. And confrontation situation in which it indeed was.
Those women were too. Threatened about their relationships i think.
And that's that's when we talked earlier about six of them within communities we didn't call it six season
but i think that's a pretty appropriate word to use. I don't see the issues of success and.
Have been dealt with in individual communities or the community at large. And i'm very saddened by that.
I can only do that myself in a.